[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le journal de tv
78 nous sommes le jeudi 12 mai voici les
titres
une deuxième édition de la bave s'ouvre
à versailles la biennale d'architecturé
de paysage de la région ile de france
est ouverte jusqu'au 13 juillet au
programme expositions visites ateliers
débats et conférences sur le thème cette
année de terre et ville françois de
mazières maire de versailles est notre
invité les électeurs de mantes-la-jolie
appelés aux urnes ce week-end pour élire
leur nouveau maire le premier tour de
l'élection municipale partielle se tient
dimanche un scrutin rendu nécessaire
après la démission en janvier de
l'ancien édile raphaël connais qui sont
les candidats et quels sont les enjeux
le point à suivre et depuis peu le parc
de la brune et riz à orgeval et
labellisé il reconnu comme ensemble
arboré remarquable un statut qui va
permettre plus de protection et
d'entretien de ces arbres pluri
centenaire est un petit voyage aussi du
côté de berlin dans cette édition avec
nos confrères de radio sensations
[Musique]
c'est le coup d'envoi de la deuxième
édition de la biennale d'architecturé de
paysage à versailles elle est initiée
par la région ile de france et sa
présidente valérie pécresse elle débute
demain vendredi et se déroulera jusqu'au
13 juillet à versailles le thème cette
année terre et villes avec comme
principale préoccupation l'environnement
les précisions de mathilde de franco
trois ans après sa première édition la
biennale d'architecturé du paysage
revient à versailles cette année le
thème est consacré au lien entre la
terre et les villes avec un fort accent
sur le développement durable à l'heure
où les ressources terrestres se
raréfient et le climat se dérègle les
architectes se mobilisent et innove on a
choisi de construire l'exposition en
trois temps un temps de monstration
cette monumentale des ressources qui est
derrière nous qu'il fait la part belle à
toutes les ressources du sous-sol et du
sol mais aussi de l'atmosphère de la
région une deuxième séquence de
témoignages de pratique on a invité des
architectes du monde entier à nous
montrer ce qu'ils font avec ces matières
et les nouvelles architectures qui sont
en train d'inventer pour répondre à
l'urgence climatique et puis un
troisième grand temps qui sera une
appropriation proposé aux étudiants et
au public de ces mêmes sujets avec des
workshops pour construire en terre quand
seul en paille faux sapin dans les deux
mois de la biennale parce qu'on trouve
je pense très très enrichissant c'est la
diversité des approches de cette même
question mais qui converge avec vers
cette même volonté de trouver des
nouvelles manières d2 de répondre au
changement climatique et à ses enjeux
environnementaux
au total la bap regroupe neuf
expositions cette année elle s'ouvre
également sur le monde avec la présence
des trois lauréats du prix de l'
architecture soutenable mexique jordanie
thaïlande présentent ainsi trois
pavillons c'était une grande grande
honneur d'être invité par valérie
pécresse avec carte blanche elle a dit
ahmed mois le monde à versailles
aujourd'hui en europe on a des grandes
récherche en termes de nouveaux
matérialité recyclage biosourcés comme
la cellulose la terre poule vérité tout
type de fibres qui on cherche de
réutiliser dans nos processus de
construction dans le nouveau monde on a
beaucoup moins des moyens des
développements et les recherches c'est
une fierté à deux titres dans ce que je
fais pas mal du coup je pense que c'est
maintenant le plus grand événement le
plus le plus grand événement festif en
architecture en france un très
clairement et aussi parce que c'est une
biennale qui est en train de s'ancrer
dans le débat ce développement durable
c'est à dire qu'ils entendent ancrer le
fait que ça concerne les architectes que
les architectes sont parties prenantes
delà de l'adaptation au réchauffement et
parce qu'il s'agit mais plus lutter
contre de l'adaptation au réchauffement
climatique ils ont leur mot à dire cette
seconde édition de la bap se tiendra
jusqu'au 13 juillet tout du long les
visiteurs pourront assister à des débats
des ateliers des conférences ou encore
des spectacles et pour parler de ce
sujet françois de mazières maire de
versailles qui est aussi le commissaire
général de cet événement un la biennale
d'architecturé de paysage devait être
notre invité mais à l'heure où je vous
parle 18h07 il ne s'est toujours pas
connecté peut-être qu'il le fera et
d'ici à la fin de cette édition pour
nous parler de cet événement je vous le
rappelle qui revient après une période
de pandémie à la première édition de
cette bape qui s'était déroulée à
versailles en 2019 deuxième édition donc
en 2022 avec cette année terry ville
ville au pluriel et tous ces liens qui
lient à entre la terre et les villes un
lien indéniable avec bien sûr une prise
en conscience et en considération de
cette thématique de l'urgence climatique
qui prend aujourd'hui une place
prépondérante je vous rappelle que c'est
donc jusqu'au 13 juillet neuf
expositions sont au programme mais aussi
davis des ateliers débats et conférences
dans toute la ville le programme complet
est à retrouver sur le site qui
s'affiche en bas de l'écran et pour
précisions cet événement de la bap avait
réuni en 2019 deux cent mille visiteurs
on imagine que l'objectif cette année
est d'attirer un peu plus de visiteurs
je vous précise de nouveau les dates 13
mai 13 juillet pour la date de ce bac 2
7 bat biennale d'architecturé de paysage
à versailles s'est ouvert à tous sauf
les lundis les horaires 12h 19h dès 11
heures les samedis et dimanches et
l'entrée est libre pour cet événement
[Musique]
dans le reste de l'actualité les
élections législatives qui approchent
c'est les 12 et 19 juin prochains les
candidatures pour le scrutin se révèle
peu à peu et l'union pour les yvelines
de la droite et du centre a investi ses
douze candidats une liste
majoritairement renouveler et ancrée
dans le territoire céline charles
l'expérience du terrain et la proximité
avec les habitants c'est ce que prône
l'union pour les yvelines de la droite
et du centre elle a fait le choix d'une
liste majoritairement nouvelles avec
notamment de nombreux élus locaux je
pense que c'est important de pouvoir un
petit peu faire ses classes et donc je
suis élu en tant que maire adjoint
depuis
près de trois mandats conseiller
départemental depuis deux mandats ça
fait trente ans que je suis élu à thoiry
donc il faut effectivement qu'il ya des
gens comme moi qu'ils soient députés
pour pouvoir défendre nos territoires et
surtout faire voter des lois qui
correspondent à la volonté des gens et
non pas seulement la volonté les grands
manitous qu'est ce qu'un député pour eux
est ce que c'est quelqu'un qui fait
simplement partie d'un groupe qui appuie
sur verre quand on lui dit des mots clés
sur verre et qui appuient ce rouge quand
on lui dit d'appeler ce rouge ou est-ce
que c'est quelqu'un qui réfléchit par
lui même qui propose les choses qui
défend des choses auxquelles il croit
sincèrement c'est une liste qu est la
caractéristique d'avoir effectivement
des élus locaux départementaux
municipaux régionaux parce que nous
croyons que l'expérience qu'ils vont
qu'ils ont récupéré sur leur terrain
peut servir à l'échelon national
philippe benassaya et michel vialay sont
les deux seuls candidats sortants
l'occasion de donner une continuité au
dossier menée sur leur territoire
respectif est élu député en septembre va
donc je reste dans une dynamique j'ai
pas fini mon travail j'ai pas fini de
d'étudier les dossiers de recevoir la
population moi je suis en début de
mandat entre guillemets alors qu'on est
en fin de mandat officiellement 12
candidats qui font le choix de
s'inscrire dans une opposition
constructive à la politique
présidentielle il faut qu'on le même le
président avoir le courage de porter les
réformes qu'il apple courage de porter
sur la retraite par exemple on saura le
faire vous semble acquis mais aussi été
frappée clé une opposition constructive
à l'assemblée nationale
et que les électeurs et à terme un choix
autre que
maquereau ou
l'extrême chaque fois que les
propositions du gouvernement nous agrée
rond nous éviterons chaque fois que les
propositions nous agrée rond dans les
grandes lignes mais avec tel ou tel
point qu'ils ne nous conviendra pas nous
les amènerons mais en tout cas nous nous
serons pas d'éclats coeur de pupitre
comme l'extrême droite comme l'extrême
gauche des candidats centrée sur des
valeurs et sujet commun le pouvoir
d'achat l'environnement la santé la
justice ou encore l'éducation ils vont
officiellement lancé leur campagne le 13
mai lors d'une réunion publique à bois
d'arcy
et ce scrutin lui a lieu ce week-end les
électeurs de mantes-la-jolie sont
appelés aux urnes pour une élection
municipale partielle premier tour ce
dimanche 15 mai un éventuel deuxième
tour le dimanche 22 mai pour en parler
céline charles est avec moi en plateau
bonsoir de la rédaction de tv 78
pourquoi vote ont à nouveau à mantes la
jolie et ben pourquoi va-t-on anovo
rappelons le l'ancien maire de
mantes-la-jolie raphaël cogner avait
démissionné de ses fonctions en janvier
dernier une situation qui avait été le
fruit de la guerre ouverte qu'il
entretenait avec le président du
département des yvelines pierre bédier
qui avait pourtant été son mentor à ses
débuts dans la vie politique donc les
conflits ont commencé quand raphaël
cogner est devenue mère en 2020 car
bédié alors un de ses conseillers
municipaux à vivement critiquer sa
politique notamment sur la gestion du
quartier du val fourré s'en est suivi
des divisions au sein de la majorité des
élus du conseil municipal 22 élus
étaient plutôt pour pierre bédier 14
pour raphaël cogner comme conséquence et
cela a entraîné le blocage du conseil
municipal donc de la prise de décision
donc forcément d'action aussi une
situation qui avait été invivable et qui
a conduit finalement à la définition de
hrw à elle cognait mais le maire
démissionnaire n'en a pas pour autant
dit son dernier mot puisqu'il est de
nouveau candidat avec sa liste sans
étiquette un nouveau cap pour mantes la
jolie il veut renverser le système est
proposé du renouveau pour la ville autre
candidat de la majorité sortante
jean-luc santini fidèles de pierre
bédier qui étaient en désaccord avec
raphaël cogné avec sa liste menthe unis
pour l'avenir il repart également avec
huit adjoints de la dernière majorité
dont le président du conseil
départemental des yvelines c'est donc
une élection tendue dont le scrutin
représente de forts enjeux pour les deux
hommes et leurs conflits avec six listes
candidates 1 qui sont sur cette ligne de
départ pour ce scrutin partiel
1 et i la gauche est ce que l'union est
au rendez-vous pour justement tenter de
remporter cette ville de mantes la jolie
alors à gauche certains se sont unis
effectivement la france insoumise europe
ecologie les verts et le parti
socialiste se sont rassemblés une équipe
de gauche mené par guillaume quévarec et
sa liste printemps mentait d'autres font
plutôt bande à part le parti communiste
est membre de l'opposition municipale
marque je n'ai mené par marc genêt
repart pour un nouveau scrutin avec sa
liste mieux vivre à mantes la jolie on
retrouve aussi thierry gonot pour lutte
ouvrière une liste majoritairement
composée d'employés et d'ouvriers
mantois et montereau mantaise est
également candidat dans le scrutin dans
ce scrutin françois gerber et sa liste
pour vous pour mantes elle est soutenue
par la république en marche et propose
un projet qui veut s'inscrire dans la
rupture de la politique actuelle de la
ville alors même si ces listes
s'opposent sur le papier plusieurs
thématiques sont récurrentes chez les
candidats on retrouve notamment le
rafraîchissement du centre ville et la
rénovation de certains quartier du val
fourré la sauvegarde des commerces la
jeunesse et l'éducation le logement ou
encore l'environnement alors vous
l'aurez compris cette élection est un
petit peu à l'image d'un échiquier où
chacun avance ses pions mais les jeux ne
sont pas encore faits réponse dans trois
jours pour le premier scrutin le
deuxième aura lieu le 22 mai prochain
bloc éventuel deuxième tour le 22 mai
avec six listes candidates pour ce
scrutin partiel qui a lieu à
mantes-la-jolie merci céline charles
pour toutes ces précisions
[Musique]
mais l'actualité c'est aussi cet
événement l'entreprise et leur manne
teyton france a présenté aujourd'hui son
un nouveau thé cloud il a été inauguré
du côté de son site de trappes c'est une
entreprise et qui est présente depuis à
60 ans sur le territoire de saint
quentin en yvelines pour ce nouveau
techcenter un investissement à hauteur
d'un million d'euros soutenu par le plan
en france relance pour ce groupe
spécialisé dans la production de pièces
en plastique est notamment dans les
secteurs de l'automobile ou de
l'aéronautique l'objectif est d' innover
pour développer une production
éco-responsable on écoute à ce propos le
directeur général interrogé par nicolas
landry
ces trois nouvelles presses clan n'a
derrière moi qu'ils se font
respectivement 60 100 et 200 tonnes
elles sont alimentées par de
l'électricité ne sont pas hydraulique
donc ça nous permet d'avoir une
empreinte environnementale réduite de
30% et elles se doivent d'être
représentative des prêts ce que l'on a à
l'atelier de fabrication pour que comme
vous l'avez compris les réglages que
l'on va optimiser ici puissent être
transposable au niveau de notre atelier
production le tech center chez nous va
nous permettre de travailler sur des
nouveaux matériaux des biomatériaux
moins demandeuses d'énergie fossile on
travaille sur des notamment des produits
venant de la mer donc ça nous permet de
tester ces matériaux là ça va nous
permettre aussi d'optimiser les réglages
de notre outil industriel pour qu'on les
applique après ses réglages au niveau de
notre centre de production en jeu de
l'autre côté un déplacement en allemagne
de la maison de l'europe des yvelines la
structure a participé à l'inauguration
d'une bibliothèque ce devant le lycée
technologique de l'automobile de berlin
au programme conférence sur l'impact
positif de ces biblioblog sur
l'environnement et la visite des lycées
centres et de ce lycée centrée sur les
énergies de demain et le hêtre
développement durable reportage pour nos
confrères de radio sensations de jessy
moulin la littérature à portée de main
dans les rues de berlin des bibliobus se
sont installés pour faciliter
l'accessibilité à la culture un projet
organisé par l'institut pour la
durabilité dans l'éducation le travail
et la culture de berlin et la maison de
l'europe désir dans ce concept affiche
boxe thaï maharajah est ce que le
concept de la vivez aux bucks c'est
surtout un concept durable il est
d'abord question de récupérer et de
transformer une vieille cabine
téléphonique en quelque chose de nouveau
nom et à savoir une petite bibliothèque
de rue qu'on place dans un lieu
stratégique des lettres comme il est
raté engagé dans le développement
durable trois aspects pratiques mart
l'occasion pour la délégation française
de participer à une conférence sur
l'environnement à travers le projet et
la mise en service de plusieurs
biblioblog ce en france et en allemagne
ça permet de véhiculer à la fois là un
concept culturel évidemment mais aussi
de d'économie circulaire oran c'est
qu'aujourd'hui il ne peut pas y avoir de
comportements vertueux et d'avancées en
matière de transition écologique sans
que le sujet de l'économie circulaire ne
soit pris au sérieux et de manière
prégnante dans nos territoires la visite
de lycée berlinois engagés sur les
thématiques des mobilité de demain et du
développement durable étaient également
au programme avec une démarche
volontaire vers la jeune génération si
jabot à passer en france on n'écoute pas
assez les jeunes et franchement il faut
écouter les jeunes là aussi il ya un un
creuset d'innovation absolument
incroyable et exponentielle et je pense
que c'est un élément essentiel on doit
prendre des exemples à ce niveau-là ça
c'est certain ce vendredi c'est au tour
de la délégation allemande de se rendre
dans les yvelines avec l'inauguration
d'une bibliothèque ce à
saint-germain-en-laye autre inauguration
ce jeudi celle du verger partagée de
maurepas au square liliane de la morte
hier c'est le deuxième espace du genre
que la ville propose à ses habitants
après celui du square de beaufortain 39
avant tout ont été plantés par la
municipalité
pommiers poiriers pruniers 55 arbustes
framboisiers myrtilles et cassissiers
des groseillers des carrés potagers le
principe c'est que les fruits seront à
la disposition de tous en libre service
un projet chiffré à 50000 euros financés
par des subventions à hauteur de 70 %
notamment de la région ile-de-france
dans le cadre de son budget participatif
enfin direction orgeval pour refermer
cette édition depuis fin avril le parc
de la brune et riz a obtenu un label
ensemble arboré remarquable avec des
arbres pluri centenaire le domaine doit
désormais être protégés entretenu c'est
l'association des amis du domaine de la
brune a tree qui a porté le projet célia
gars de son go et mathilde franco
[Musique]
de 10 mètres de haut se châtaigniers du
xviiie siècle est considéré comme arbre
remarquable
il fait partie de ces végétaux qui ont
permis au parc de la brune et reed
orgeval d'obtenir le label ensemble à
rebours est remarquable nous avons
sélectionné des arbres qui ont eu le
plus riche centenaire donc notamment il
y en a un qui est emblématique est
derrière moi un pain noir qui lui vont
datent du 19e et qui a été justement qui
nous a fait gagner une partie de ces de
ce label il ya aussi des châtaigniers un
peu plus loin petit date qui ont 300 ans
l'association les amis du domaine de la
brune et riz a voulu préserver ce parc
de 5 ha paysager en obtenant le label
c'est un engagement à entretenir ce
patrimoine arboré un lieu qui va devenir
à la fois un environnement naturel est
un endroit de convivialité
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on va faire des aménagements importants
notamment artistiques
avec ce qu'on appelle une arboré al sur
la sur l'esplanade qui servira de halle
également il y aura une toile qui sera
tendu il y aura des animations y voir
des concerts il va y avoir les
animations associatives donc c'est un
parent qui va vivre de la même manière
cette association nous a incités à voter
en conseil municipal également la
déclaration des droits de l'arbre qui
montre bien à quel point ce sujet
intéresse notre notre commune document
qui marque une volonté de mettre l'arbre
au centre des préoccupations de la ville
d'orgeval elle est affichée à deux
entrées du parc de la poule est très
et je vous rappelle la principale
information de cette édition l'ouverture
demain vendredi à à versailles de la
biennale d'architecturé de paysage qui
revient pour une deuxième édition dans
la cité royale le thème cette année
était revil le lien indéniable entre les
deux avec aussi la notion de
développement durable de l'urgence
climatique qui prend aujourd'hui une
place prépondérante nous devions avoir
en invité françois de mazières maire de
versailles également commissaire général
de cette biennale d'architecturé de
paysage avec nous par visioconférence il
ne s'est toujours pas connecté c'est pas
grave on pourra l'interroger peut-être
un peu plus tard sur cet événement qui
se termine donc le 13 juillet donc ça va
durer assez longtemps du côté de la
ville de versailles 9 expositions mais
aussi des visites ateliers débats et
conférences s'est ouvert tous les jours
sauf le lundi de 12h à 19h dès 11 heures
les samedi et dimanche l'entrée est
libre et le programme complet est à
retrouver sur le site internet de la bac
qui s'affiche en bas de l'écran voilà
c'est la fin de ce journal merci de
votre fidélité demain vendredi vous avez
rendez vous avec le 7-8 week-end une
émission avec de l'actualité des idées
de sorties pour bien terminer la semaine
dans les yvelines belle soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]
trop